what's up elimination it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
want to see that big idea that you have
inside you come to life so you can have
a huge impact on the world and so to
help you on your journey today we're
gonna look at how billionaires think
success advice from the top vol 5 and as
always guys as you're watching if you
hear a message that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick with yourself as well enjoy so
up first is Mark Cuban and his message
work hard I knew I was wired to be
excited about business how or why I
don't know but you know and there's
certain guys they have the genetics to
jump out of the gym right certain guys
you know that you know when they golf
they have the muscle memory and and the
discipline you know Dirk Nowitzki may
not be the most talented guy in the NBA
but his discipline and his focus to do
what's necessary to be successful he's
willing to do and combine it with being
seven feet tall and being skilled you
know it makes him an amazing basketball
player so it's understanding what your
skill set is finding the right place to
use those skills and then going for it
you know will that make you 250 grand it
depends if you pick the right industry
but whatever industry you pick if you
outwork everybody if you try to be a
little smarter than everybody if you try
to be a better salesperson and everybody
if you try to be better prepared than
everybody you've got your best chance
because if you don't do it and somebody
else does you know I have the same work
like someone's trying to take it all
away from you you know work you actually
work like someone's spending 24 hours
working 24 hours to take it all away
from you and that's kind of the way I
look at it I remember asking my dad to I
want a new basketball shoes because I
was a basketball junkie back then he's
like well your shoes work if you want a
new pair of tennis shoes you have to go
out there and get a job and I'm like dad
I'm 12 years old and it just so happens
he was playing poker with his buddies
and one of his buddies just like well I
got a job for you I've got these garbage
bags that we distribute you could sell
them door-to-door I'm like okay and it
was when I was selling them and realized
he
I'd like to sell and that I could sell
and that I recognize that selling was
was about providing the service and
creating value for people that I knew
that I would literally back then I knew
that I could always succeed I mean I
remember I was 16 I think when I started
a stamp company and started going to
stamp shows and trade shows and just
working a little bit harder than other
people and and trading up from one stamp
to the next I remember one time I
started with a quarter and bought a
stamp and left with $50 thinking hey if
I could do this I could do anything and
and it's not that everything worked I
failed a lot but I never ever felt like
I I wouldn't be able to work hard enough
to succeed next Jeff Bezos take bold
bets my job one of my jobs as the leader
of Amazon is to encourage people to be
bold and people love to focus on things
that aren't yet working and that's good
it's human nature that kind of divine
discontent can be very helpful but you
really you know it's incredibly hard to
get people to take bold bets and you
need to encourage that and if you're
gonna take bold bets they're gonna be
experiments and if their experiments you
don't know ahead of time though they're
gonna work
experiments are by their very nature
prone to failure but big success is a
few big successes compensate for dozens
and dozens of things that didn't work so
you know bold bets AWS Kindle Amazon
Prime our 3rd party seller business all
of those things are examples of bold
bets that that did work and they pay for
a lot of experiments I've made billions
of dollars of failures at Amazon com
literally billions of dollars of
failures and you know you might remember
pets.com or cosmo or you know give
myself a root canal with no anesthesia
very easily none of those things are fun
but but they also they don't matter what
really matters is companies that don't
continue to experiment companies that
don't embrace failure they eventually
get in the desperate position where they
only thing they can do is make a kind of
Hail Mary bet at the very end of their
corporate existence
whereas companies that are you know
making bets all along even you know big
bets but not bet the company bets I
don't I don't believe in bet the company
bets that's when you're desperate
that's that's the last thing you can do
coming in at number three Elon Musk have
a high pain threshold when does have to
be focused on for short time and money
coming in when creating company because
otherwise the company will for die so
that the I think that a lot of times
people think like creating company is
gonna be fun I would say it's not it's
really not that fun when there are
periods of fun and there are periods of
where it's just awful and particularly
if you CEO of the company you actually
have a distillation of all the worst
problems in a company there's no point
in spending your time on things that are
going right so you only spend on things
on your time on things that are going
wrong and and there are things that are
going wrong that other people can't
can't take care of so you're like the
worst you have a filter for the
crappiest problems in the company the
most pernicious and painful problem so I
wouldn't say it's it's I think you have
to feel quite compelled to do it and
have a fairly high pain threshold and
there's a friend of mine who says like
starting companies like staring into the
abyss and eating glass and there's some
truth to that
we're staring into the abyss part is
that you're going to be constantly
facing the extermination of the company
because most startups fail that's like
90% ugly 99% of Starks fail so I so you
that that's the staring into the abyss
part you can't so constantly saying okay
if I don't get this right the company
will die it should be quite stressful
quite stressful and then the eating
glass part is you've got you've got to
do you've got to do the problems you're
gonna start you're gonna work in the
problem that the company needs you to
work on not the problems you want to
work on and so that the that's your
knife working on problems that that
you'd really wish you weren't working on
and so that's the eating glass part then
that goes on for a long time so how do
you keep your focus on the big picture
when you're constantly faced with we
could be out of business in a month well
it's just a very small percentage of
mental energy is on the on the big
picture like you know you know you know
where you generally heading for and and
the actual path is going to be some sort
of zigzagging thing in that direction
and try not to deviate too far from the
path like that that you want to be on
but you're gonna have to do that some
degree but I don't want to I don't want
to diminish that I mean I think the
product the profit motive is it is a is
a good one if the rules of an industry
are properly set up so there's something
fundamentally wrong with profit in fact
profit just means that people are paying
you more for whatever you're doing then
you're spending to create it that's a
good thing and if you're not if that's
not the case then you'll be out of
business and rightfully so sure you're
not adding enough value and number four
Mark Zuckerberg you get what you spend
your time doing first don't focus on it
right I mean I think like you basically
get what you spend your time doing right
I mean I want the company to build three
products this year and we're gonna work
on a few others because people are
interested in them but those are the
three things that I'm spending my
product time on right you
get what you put into it if you spend a
third of your time
trying to make the people around you
better through getting better people
mentoring getting them to be better
getting the best people in your
organization and you're known to more
impactful roles and I think over time
not just a cruise and you get a better
organization number five is Richard
Branson be positive whatever job you're
doing in life you know if you're if
you're a switchboard operator if you're
cleaning the floors of a you know a
building you know if you're you know
collecting eggs for an incubator you
know whatever it is if you you know if
you're positive about the job you're
doing you're gonna get you're gonna be a
much happier person and the people
around you're gonna be a lot happier and
it's likely that you know that you won't
forever be a cleaning lady or you know
because yeah because you're smiling
because you're happy people will you
know promote you and you'll go on and do
great things in life so I think a
positive attitude is essential in life
for whatever your position and number
six is Larry Ellison have the right
product we probably spend less money in
marketing than any company our size in
the world we have a tiny marketing
department and everybody's won quite
oracles you know all that sales and
marketing we are the largest employer of
MIT and Caltech engineers in the world
we are the largest employer of Stanford
and Harvard and CMU mathematicians in
the world we are overwhelmingly
dominated by engineering at Oracle the
idea that we are a sales and marketing
company which people will sometimes will
write about quite often is ludicrous on
the face of it because all of our
customers who buy Oracle already
happened and if you already have Oracle
there's nothing a salesman can tell you
about how great it is to make you buy
more GE already uses it the defense
department always you early is that all
of our customers ninety-eight percent of
our sales or more are to existing Oracle
customers if we don't have the right
product people don't buy more we will
before the acquisition we spend three
billion dollars a year
in software engineering the company is
all about engineering it's the only
thing that works
number seven is Sean Parker fail your
way to success what did you learn from
from starting so early and what have you
learned from your failures because I
know that failures are kind of the only
way you really learn right mhm yeah I
get I usually either this is the correct
way to ask the question because I
usually get asked the question you know
how did you succeed and I and I really
don't feel like I've succeeded I feel
like I've I've sort of failed
systematically at least in terms of my
own goals and you know what I what I set
out to do but then somehow failure has
kind of you know transformed into some
weird kind of success that I wasn't that
I wasn't really expecting and number
eight is add value from Vinodh Khosla
add some value there's a true societal
and business value proposition there's a
contribution I find and I don't do this
for reasons other than the fact that you
can't long term build a viable business
without making a real contribution most
people look at they can start a business
do an IPO make some money almost always
that leads to businesses that are round
trips what I call good they go up and go
down to build a durable business you
really have to focus on the value
proposition committed at number nine is
be flexible and nimble lloyd blankfein
you're gonna have to be you know
flexible and nimble in your life that's
the that's the characteristic you want
to get you don't it's not important
whether you know what the product is of
the shore or what's hot and what's not
or how to execute this particular thing
you you need to learn business and you
need to learn had a question and have an
open mind you need to know the process
of thinking about things you notice how
people can go around and be an investor
in this industry turn around without
doing anything being a great investor in
another industry or
some CEO one day is running Ford Motor
Company then can run Boeing or different
industries because it's not but the most
important thing is not the particular
characteristics of a particular industry
or thing it's how to be a good CEO just
like it's how to be a present how to
have presentation skills how to be a
good manager how to be a good
subordinate how to be a good partner how
to use people how to be usable by people
how you know and those are the things
that you have to learn now you can only
learn it you can't learn it abstractly
and you can't really learn it in school
you have to learn it by doing a number
10 is visualized with Sara Blakely
I've visualized this for myself when I
was selling copiers door-to-door I had a
very clear vision of what my life was
gonna be like and I encourage everyone
to do it take a snap photo of what
success looks like for you are you how
many employees do you have or how much
are you making where do you live what
are you sitting at a table with world
leaders are you standing on a stage in
New York City giving a speech and hold
on to that that snapshot and you will
subconsciously start to make decisions
that get you there and so my snap photo
for myself when I was going door-to-door
to sell copiers was to be self-employed
invent a product that I could sell to
lots of people and not just one copier
to each person and create a business for
myself that would continue to fund
itself if I wasn't present I wanted
money to be generated without me having
to be there I was that specific in my
vision thank you guys for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
was your favorite lesson from this video
that you're going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
leave it on the comments below I'm
really curious to hear what you have to
say thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope to continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
Oh
wolves long meow
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be to like a little beacon
hey believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]